>>> TONIGHT CNN LEARNING ALL 16
OFEORGIA'S FAKE ELECTORS W
TRIED TO OVERTURN GEORGIA'S 2020
ELECTION RESULTS, TURN THE STATE
TO FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP, ARE
NOW TARGETS OF THE FULTON COUNTY
D.A.'S CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER MAJOR SIGN
THAT THE INVESTIGATION INTO
TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION IS PROCEEDING RAPIDLY
IN GEORGIA.
THERE HAS BEEN A FLURRY OF
ACTIVITY IN RECENT DAYS.
DONALD TRUMP'S FORMER WHITE
HOUSE ATTORNEY TOLD US, QUOTE,
THE GEORGIA CASE UNDER THE
CONTROL OF THE FULTON COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY APPEARS TO
POSE A SERIOUS THREAT OF
INDICTMENT TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
EVAN PEREZ IS OUT FRONT.
THOSE WORDS WHY TY COBB ARE
SIGNIFICANT, SENDING LETTERS TO
ALL 16 OF THOSE FAKE ELECTORS
SAYING THEY'RE NO LONGER JUST
WITNESSES BUT TARGETS OF A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
TELL ME HOW SIGNIFICANT THIS IS,
WHAT IT COULD MEAN FOR TRUMP.
>> IT'S A BIG DEAL FOR A
PROSECUTOR TO GO FROM THE POINT
POSITION WHERE THESE PEOPLE WERE
CONSIDERED TO BE WITNESSES,
ERIN, AND NOW THEY ARE POSSIBLY
GOING TO FACE CHARGES.
WHAT IT TELLS US THE PROSECUTORS
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THEY'VE GOTTEN WHICH
THEY BELIEVE COULD LEAD TO
CHARGES.
AND, OF COURSE, THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO WERE WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN,
WITH HIS LAWYERS.
WE KNOW THAT THEY WERE
COORDINATING THIS FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN AND
HIS LEGAL TEAM AND, OF COURSE,
THAT BRINGS US CLOSER TO DONALD
TRUMP HIMSELF.
AND THAT'S THE REASON TY COBB IS
MAKING THAT STATEMENT.
FROM THE GEORGIA INVESTIGATION
PERSPECTIVE YOU CAN SEE HOW YOU
CAN GET FROM THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
COORDINATING THIS EFFORT TO
ADVANCE THESE FAKE ELECTORS TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WHO WAS THE
MAN DRIVING ALL OF THIS
ACCORDING TO SOME OF THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY WE'VE HEARD.
>> NOW WE MENTIONED FULTON
COUNTY AND HOW QUICKLY THINGS
ARE MOVING THERE.
JUST YESTERDAY WE FOUND OUT THE
FULTON COUNTY D.A. SUBPOENAED
THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JODI
HEISS, A MAJOR ALLY OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHO ALSO VOTED TO OVERTURN
THE ELECTION.
YAHOO NEWS REPORTED THAT THE
D.A. SENT LETTERS TO MULTIPLE
GEORGIA REPUBLICANS THAT THEY
COULD BE INDICTED.
HOW QUICKLY, EVAN, FROM THE
CONTEXT YOU HAVE IS THIS
INVESTIGATION MOVING IN GEORGIA,
THIS CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
THERE, COMPARED TO THE DOJ?
>> WELL, THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING.
THE GEORGIA INVESTIGATION,
FRANKLY, IS A LOT SIMPLER.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE STATE,
RIGHT.
I THINK YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
SPEED WITH WHICH FANI WILLIS'
OFFICE IS MOVING THEY BELIEVE
THEY HAVE SOMETHING THEY CAN GET
AT, AT LEAST POSSIBLY MAYBE
BRINGING CHARGES AND MAYBE
HAVING SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE END
UP COOPERATING AGAINST SOMEONE
HIGHER WHICH WOULD BE, OF
COURSE, THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
IN THE CASE OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THEY HAVE PERHAPS A
LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE THEY ARE
LOOKING AT THE PROCESS ACROSS
SEVEN STATES, ERIN.
IT'S NOT JUST GEORGIA.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT OTHER STATES
AND ALL OF THESE ELECTORS,
DOZENS OF THEM.
THAT IS A COMPLICATED
INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS ALSO, BY
THE WAY, MOVING MORE QUICKLY
THAN PEOPLE REALIZE.
>> EVAN PEREZ, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO ALL 16, YES 16, DEEP
ELECTORS IN GEORGIA WHERE PART
OF THE PLAN TO OVERTURN THE
2020 ELECTION ON BEHALF OF
DONALD TRUMP ARE NOW TARGETS
AND A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
TONIGHT.
THAT IS ACCORDING TO THE FULTON
COUNTY GEORGIA PROSECUTORS.
LOOKING INTO TRUMP'S ELECTION
DIFFERENCE IN THE STATE.
SO THIS MEAN THEY ARE CLOSER TO
DECIDING CRIMINAL CHARGES AND
IT'S THE PROBE ZHANG ANY CLOSER
TO DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF?
BACK WITH ME NOW, DOUG JONES,
SHED WILL, AT THAT GUY.
HI I START HERE BECAUSE YOU
THINK ABOUT THE WAYS IN WHICH
GEORGIA, THIS PRETTY UNIQUE IN
TERMS OF ALL OF THIS SORT OF
STATES THAT HAD DISCUSSIONS
AROUND BELIES AROUND THE
ELECTION.
GEORGIA DIDN'T SEEM TO BE
BUYING IT WHEN IT CAME TO,
OBVIOUSLY, PURDUE VERSUS COUNT.
CAMPAIGN OF HAVE THAT ANGLE.
IS THIS AN EXAMPLE OF THERE
BEING THE TRUMP FATIGUE THAT
MAKE MULVANEY WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
THE IDEA, LOOK, HE CLEARED THE
WAY THE OTHERS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT BUYING IT
ANYMORE.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO DEAL WITH
IT.
>> BUT WE SEE WITH DONALD TRUMP
GOES ALL IN.
IT CARRIES THEM ABOUT A THIRD.
ABOUT THE REST OF IT IS UP TO
THOSE CANDIDATES.
WHEN YOU HAD WAS A POPULAR
GOVERNOR WHO TOOK ON THE TRUMP
--
BUT OTHERWISE IT WAS VERY
FIRMLY IN LINE WITH TRUMP
POLICIES.
I CAN'T SOMEBODY WOULD NOT ONLY
LOST OUR SON RACE WHO DONALD
TRUMP CALLED A LOSER.
BUT SOMEONE WHO RAN A TERRIBLE
CAMPAIGN AND HAD LOST TWO YEARS
EARLIER WITH SOME HELP FROM
TRUMP.
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO INCH
AWAY FROM DONALD TRUMP.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T RUN FROM
HIM.
BUT WHAT YOU HERE ON CAPITOL
HILL, PRIVATELY, SOMETIMES IN A
VERY CRUDE LANGUAGE CENSORED BY
MITCH MCCONNELL.
SOMETHING THAT SUGGEST THAT
REPUBLICANS MOVING FORWARD IN
2024 CAN DO OTHER THINGS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEING MORE
AND MORE RHONDA SCIENTISTS,
THAT SCOTT HAS GOT BILL COMING
OUT, A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT
MAKE BABY TALKED ABOUT.
I POLITICIANS ARE OFTEN SELF
INTERESTED BIG SHOTS.
GETTING TRUMP OUT OF THE WAY --
>> WE DON'T MEAN YOU.
I [INAUDIBLE]
>> NONE THOSE PEOPLE ARE
CONDEMNING TRUMP'S ACTIONS.
THEY ARE STILL WRAPPING
THEMSELVES IN TRUMP.
FROM EVERY CANDID OUT THERE,
FROM ALABAMA EVERYWHERE
ELSEWHERE, THEY WRAPPING
THEMSELVES IN TRUMP.
THEY'RE SAYING THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN.
THEY ARE NOT CONDEMNING WHAT
THEY'VE HEARD.
IT IS JUST NOTHING BUT CRICKETS
COMING FROM CAPITOL HILL ON THE
ACTIONS THAT WERE TOOK.
AND THE THREAT TO DEMOCRACY
THAT WE SAW.
THAT, I THINK, IS A REAL
TRAGEDY.
>> WHEN YOU HEAR PRIVATELY
MODULAR PUBLICLY UNLESS LIST
SHINY AND KINZINGER ARE OFTEN
MIRROR IMAGES OF REALITY.
>> I WAS HERE THAT, AND I CAN
TELL YOU FROM SOMEONE FROM THE
ELECTORATE AND THINK ABOUT THE
IDEA OF THE PUBLIC RECENTLY
PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS.
I ASSOCIATE THOSE WITH SOME
SORT OF SHORTWAVE PUBLICLY AND
SHRINK ABOUT TO ASK FOR THE
CHANCE TO LEAVE.
IF YOU WANT TO BE A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS SOUTHEAST MYSELF WELL
MAYBE YOU SHOULD BE THE PERSON
WHO CONSEQUENCES THE NAME.
THAT IS NAIVE, PERHAPS, IN THE
WAY WASHINGTON D.C. AND SHAKING
YOUR HEAD.
BUT THE IDEA OF, WHY DO YOU
THINK STILL ALL THIS TIME THERE
IS THE RELUCTANCE TO SAY
PUBLICLY ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
IS AS BASIC AS WET MICK
MULVANEY HAD TO SAY?
THE IDEA, LOOK, THERE IS THAT
FATIGUE.
BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY'LL JUST
SAID THERE'S 30% OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE WHO REGARDLESS OF WHAT
YOU SAY IS GOING TO BE A TRUMP
VOTER.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE THERE FOR
HIM AND THEY WANT TO DEFEND
METAL COST.
AND EVERY ONE OF THOSE
POLITICIANS DO NOT WANT TO
ALIENATE THAT 30% OF THE VOTE.
THAT IS WHY YOU GOT ALL OF IT
LISTEN THAT NICK TALKED ABOUT.
NOT A SINGLE ONE OF US
CONDEMNED THE ACTIONS OF DONALD
TRUMP.
AND WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE,
DURING, AND AFTER.
THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT AND SAID
IT IS TIME TO MOVE ON BUT
EVERYBODY SAYS THAT.
IT IS TIME TO MOVE ON.
WHEN YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT A
PROBLEM AND YOU SAY WE DON'T
NEED TO LOOK AT THE LOOK AT THE
PAST WE NEED TO LOOK FORWARD.
FOLKS NEED TO STEP UP AND THEY
NEED TO PUT THIS COUNTRY FIRST.
AND START TALKING ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
AND WRAPPING THEMSELVES IN THAT
LIKE INSTEAD OF THE DONALD
TRUMP LIKE OF SILENCE.